good morning everybody um our chairman
has texted me that he has a little bit
of a family
emergency and he is on his way however
normally I would just open the hearing
and I would proceed um my understanding
is somebody has reached out to
him
and he wants to talk with that person so
I'm opening this hearing and we will be
in
recess I'm not allowed to say for about
20 minutes so we will um be in recess
and if y'all just want to like stand by
I would say come back if you have
something that you need to do or if you
need to go wander a little bit I would
you
okay good morning everyone um I
apologize for my lateness I had a
a uh college student who happens to be
my son I had to attend to um with that
we're going to begin our uh continued
hearings on baill bills that we have
retained if you would please join me for
begin I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible liberty and
justice for
memory um I believe we have a a citizen
who please um please approach the table
and S the Mike identify yourself push
the the button first till the lights red
for the benefit of the committee this is
a citizen who emailed me last night or
yesterday and requested to be heard and
I do not deny citizens um I had said we
were done taking testimony but that was
for lobbyists so the floor is yours
thank you first I'd like to thank you
you for letting me be here um just
letting being able to tell my story to
people that might have some type of
authority is very important um a little
bit about myself my name is Maryann jock
I am a lifelong resident of the North
country of New Hampshire I grew up in
Lisbon New Hampshire lived for 15 years
in Pittsburgh New Hampshire my husband
is also from the North Country I was a
public school teacher in New Hampshire
teaching Junior High high school for 15
years uh my husband owns his own
business currently I am out of the
teaching profession and I am a career
novelist and I am also currently the
elected president of Romance Writers of
America which is the only Trade
Organization for that industry in the
United States so I am well aware of the
importance of all of these things um the
reason Reon why I took the position
there was to help increase diversity and
inclusion within the romance industry
but the publishing industry as a whole
so um why am I here I am here because in
October of
2021 my tiny little Street of Eight
houses Dead End Street in Lisbon New
Hampshire was um turned upside down we
had a family that moved in and we did
not know at the time that the husband in
the family was about to be let out on
parole for um uh the the current uh
charge that he was serving time for was
extortion of the Elliott hospital and
that was after a long line of time in
the system he is 52 years old he has has
more convictions and many of them
felonies than he has years of life he
understands the justice system to he
could
probably give any lawyer a run for their
money as far as what he can and cannot
get away with the unfortunate thing is I
grew up in a middle class neighborhood
raised by family that were lifetime New
Hampshire residents with a work ethic a
belief in volunteering and a belief in
if you see something that you can make
better you should do
that um I don't know the system I've
never been in the system I've never had
to deal with the justice system I was
raised with the belief that the justice
system was put in place to protect
citizens that followed the
rules and that if I ever got into a
position where I needed somebody to
protect to me and help me that law
enforcement would be able to do that
because they protect their citizens
that's their job I have since
learned that the system is not there to
do that because in order to have a
system that works for you you have to be
educated in that system and as a
law-abiding citizen who never had to
deal with it I never had to educate
myself about it um we have been told
repeatedly by the police that that
anything they could do would not be
enough and there's no point in doing it
until he is
violent and I fully trust that the
police are doing everything they can
this man could you um could you tell us
what he did since moving in that caused
us uh what hasn't he done um one of the
things that is terribly upsetting and
I'm sure all of you most of you maybe
have the same experience that the the
idea of living a in a place where people
just start
screaming swears and veiled threats and
not so veiled threats through through
the neighborhood is something that
happens on a TV show in New York City in
in you know a a very low socioeconomic
area this is our daily reality um he
when he first moved in started screaming
that he was going to burn all our houses
down that he was going to have his
buddies come and take care of
us um he has the tendency right now he
focuses on me I refuse to allow him to
make me a victim and therefore I will
not react to anything he does but that
just puts the focus more on me um we did
have a safety net with him being on
parole because he many times um violated
his parole and ended up going back to
prison prison the first time it was like
30 days then it was 60 days and then I
believe this last stint was 3 months
when he came back from um his parole
this last time he had finished serving
out his sentence he is no longer on
parole and under supervision and two
days after he came back he stood in the
middle of our street and screamed up the
street that there was nobody to protect
us now and we could call the cops all we
wanted but he would just go and pay his3
or $40 and be home in two hours to
continue what he was
doing we again have talked repeatedly to
the police and they say call they say we
we have at my house what I call the book
of and I'm not going to say his his
first name but we have been keeping that
and recording the things that he does
and the things that he screams we have
had to buy security cameras
and put no posted uh no trespassing
signs on our house I work from home I am
usually the only one on the street
during the day by myself I have to have
my house locked all the time because he
knows I'm home alone and he knows that
there's nobody else on the street he
does not work nobody in the house Works
um currently we're in a situation where
he's also abusing the stalking and
harassment order process he has stocking
and harassment orders out on my husband
and myself conveniently my husband is a
hunter and it just happens to be opening
day next Wednesday and my husband has
had to relinquish all of his guns to the
police department because as soon as
there's a stalking or harassment order
put on you for safety reasons they do
that and and we both understand why
stocking and harassment and restrainment
orders are set up that way um and in a
perfect system where somebody is not
abusing it and using it by proxy to
torment or harass good citizens I
understand why it works um I have I have
I own a shotgun because I used to go
bird hunting I now own a Sig sour
Pro of of my own that I make sure is
between myself and my front door every
single day at home in a tiny little dead
end Street in Lisbon New Hampshire that
has eight houses on it that I grew up in
the house I own now is four generations
in my family and I'm actually
considering is it just is it worth it to
keep
it and um the reason why I'm here
today is because first off I do not
believe in just accepting my lot in
life there there's always a solution
there's always a better way and in
trying to learn Le what we need to do in
this system because we don't know the
police can only tell us what they know
parole can only tell us what they know
and for some reason one hand does not
know what the other is doing most of the
time and I called the parole department
for grafting County and again I'm not
going to say names I'm not here to point
any fingers but I talked to somebody in
charge there and that person did not
know anything about me other than that I
had this particular person living next
to me and that I was clearly a woman um
the first five minutes of the
conversation literally went like I was
wasting this man's time and he treated
me and excuse the the term but it's the
only way I could think of what I was was
in his mind that I was the crack hor
next door in the slum house and that I
was just completely wasting his time and
um um I took a breath and I said let us
get something straight I probably have
more college degrees than you I
definitely have a better vocabulary than
you and I do not live in a place where I
also have warrants out for my arrest I
have power in my voice and you need to
listen to me because I'm a
citizen and he did change his attitude a
little bit I did not get any further
answers the only answers I got was that
he actually wasn't even aware aware of
the the provisions of him being out on
parole I only knew them because I had
gone to the bail
hearing or not the bail hearing the
parole hearing my husband and I have
made it a point to go to all of those
parole hearings because it was the only
way we could learn anything and know how
to protect ourselves in this
situation um as an independent who
swings very liberal I I
appreciate the
um the intent in bail law I do not
believe that people with a first offense
or somebody that's in the wrong place at
the wrong time or God forbid a teenager
that has had trauma that's trying to
work through it deserves to be sitting
in a jail cell for months on end before
they have a chance to have a hearing I
understand the intent of bail reform the
the follow through through and the
reality of it leaves a lot to be desired
and I think it has not come to light
because most people here and most people
that that feel that their vote has
something to do or or has some power in
this state have not had to live
surrounded by these
people that that are taking the bail
reform and th throwing it back in the
state's face those are the people that
don't have the voice that feel like they
don't have the power
and I do I can come in here and I can
speak to all of you on an even level and
understand that my voice does
matter
so I said I wasn't going to cry it's
more rage cry women in here probably
understand the the the whole thing but
um you know it's just
frustrating because I'm scared in my own
home and the police have basically
said until he hurts somebody and it's a
felony level offense and there's blood
involved we can't do much other than
show up and record it and go
home so my next step is to go to the
people that make make the decisions and
tell you my story so you understand that
this is a serious problem his mental
illness whatever it may be should not
Trump my own mental health and sense of
home ma'am could you tell us um what you
would like to see us do as as as far as
this goes with relate to R to bail you
know from what I've Been Told by law
enforcement it now that he's out on
parole that he's
basically it it's kind of a clean slate
that one thing doesn't he he can be
pulled in for one thing this week and
pays his bail and goes home and he can
have something happen next week and he
goes and pays his bail and goes home and
there's no okay well you've been in here
four times this week with chargeable
misdemeanor you know maybe this is needs
to maybe you need to stay until you can
see a judge maybe after four
misdemeanors you know we bump it up to a
felony charge I I do not know because I
have not done all of the resources uh
research but I do know that he's not
only causing my family financial
hardship because we're having to pay for
secur uh for surveillance cameras I've
had to buy a dash camera I've had to buy
a handgun we just had to um get our
lawyer involved because of these
restraining orders and it's just an
ongoing thing and I know 100% that it's
putting a strain on the
municipality of the town because he's
not the only one in town that does this
we have four full-time police officers
and they right now have 400 open cases
in tiny little Lisbon New Hampshire and
I'm a taxpayer so I fully know how much
this Ridiculousness is costing me as a
taxpayer and my town we can't do things
that we would want for the citizens of
the town because we have to put our
money over here and it just feels like
every single place I look they're just
chasing their tails and there's nothing
happening could um could you tell us
what what the status is how did you
already have a hearing in court on the
um stocking orders he got against your
husband um we have had stocking orders
in the past on us what the first one was
dropped before the hearing even happened
the second one uh we actually I got to
the courthouse with my lawyer I walked
in and his wife who because he was in
prison at the time his wife dropped the
suit or dropped the order before the
hearing started in there this one
because my husband's because hunting
season starts on Wednesday and he's
supposed to be leaving Sunday for
hunting camp um we went to the the court
yesterday and asked for a quicker
hearing and we have a hearing on Tuesday
that we will have our lawyer at and I've
been compiling surveillance videos and
writing up my statements and doing
everything that I shouldn't be doing
because I have other more pressing
things to do
did um okay so the the order that's in
place now against your husband or both
of you is just the temporary order until
it gets to the what happens is when you
have a stocking or harassment order put
against you immediately first off you
lose your second amendment rights and
whatever the plaintiff wrote in the
stocking order about what they
want um the defendant to have to follow
the if the judge chooses to sign off on
it without any proof of that behavior at
all that is that so I can't go 300 feet
towards his house which it is now
November I don't go out into my yard
until it's 70 degrees again so that
doesn't impact me at all I have to um I
have to drive past his house to get off
my street it's a dead end street so for
a while the first time that was a
question whether I was even going to be
able to leave my house if he's outside
and I'm on my property I have to go
inside because my house is not 300 ft
from his house um he wanted us to take
down our surveillance cameras because he
says they're shining into his house the
um all of the police in town have seen
surveillance camera his lawyer has seen
surveillance footage from that the
parole board has seen surveillance
footage from that nobody has said that
it's illegal so we have refused to take
down the camera and the police have
looked at it live and said no you can't
can't see in there um so we haven't done
that again my husband had to give up all
of his
guns um and that goes into effect
immediately when the police show up at
your house and then that stays in effect
until you get to the hearing and then
the judge decides if it's going to stay
in effect for 365 days or not did the
judge who signed off on this is he the
same one who was sitting on the cases
that were dismissed before they were
started no that the other problem is
that again one hand does not know what
the other hand is doing so this is an
actual a new judge in the circuit court
and um so they probably have no context
for what this person is because we have
been told by the police you know once
this happens a couple of times the judge
is going to get wise to it and they
won't they won't approve it but again
you know there's a new judge now we have
to start this all over again okay thank
you any questions from the
committee yes representative
Muse sorry my teach my old teacher came
out on me put your hand up I'll call on
you thanks for coming in to testify you
you you had said that um uh there have
been at least one occasion where he's
been arrested multiple times on
misdemeanor charges in the
neighborhood uh um what were the charges
and what were the circumstances that
were involved in that um most recently
and he actually I don't believe has
gotten the arrest warrant yet they were
working on it him and his wife egged my
neighbor's
car um which was caught on my
surveillance camera he has been um
charged with disorderly conduct um
destruction of property the last thing
that sent him away um because of a par
violation was he moved a property pin
and it was caught on camera that he
moved the pin and and took it completely
out of the ground and walked away with
it um threatening a lot of threatening
but the police as overwhelmed as they
are you know it's to their discretion to
decide if it's a chargeable offense and
it's paperwork and it's a lot of
paperwork and it's time that they aren't
spending on more important things I
understand that in the grand scheme of
things my inconvenience as a citizen is
not as important as somebody else's
trauma um but you know so a lot of the
things that
we um fill out statements for it it
doesn't really go
anywhere so but I believe the last time
he had a total of 17 charges when he
ended up um violating parole and this
this was in in in the span of like a
couple of months cuz he' come out of
parole or out of jail on parole and
within a couple of months it was like 17
charges could you narrow it down though
to the to the times where he was
arrested for her misdemeanor and bailed
and then rearrested and bailed do you do
you have we we don't get that
information really um you know we will
put in a statement MH and I know there
was one time and it's the statute of
limitations is probably cleared on this
cuz it was early on when they first
moved here he had his wife get in the
car and drive to the end of our street
at a very high rate of speed and again
we're at a dead end Street the woman
that lives at the end of the street is a
single mother with a teenage daughter
and he started screaming at her in the
driveway that she better sleep with one
eye open and that she has to leave her
house
sometime and on his way back down the
road our other neighbor had come out to
see if he had to go up and help our
neighbor at all and as he's coming down
the street in the car his wife is
driving he's got the door open he's
screaming run him over hit him run him
over hit him as they're coming down the
street um he was he did get charged with
that but I I do not
know where that that went so I can't
tell you how many times he's actually
been around Ed because to be perfectly
honest it it's not something that
happens in in a clear span of time I
mean he he egged the car
Sunday they still haven't gotten the
arrest warrant completely figured out
and approved so they could show up
Friday and or call him and say you need
to come down to the PD and sign
paperwork and he pays his bail and he
comes home and we are none the
wiser okay further
questions representative Stone thank you
one of other question I have is have
your husband had a final hearing on the
stalking order no that's going to be
Tuesday and are you we've had one before
and well not a hearing because it's
always been dropped before the hearing
comes follow up Mr chairman sure follow
up do you feel that this process of uh
him seeking any stalking order has been
weaponized against you and your husband
Muse okay um see you no further
questions thank you very much I know you
had a long drive down here and we are
definitely going to take your testimony
into consideration as we debate and uh
sort through these bills okay thank you
so much for giving me the time and thank
you for the work that you do that you do
do
you
all right with that we're going to just
take a a five um 10 minutes actually 10
minutes and we're going to get ready to
when we reconvene in 10 minutes we're
going to start working on the um the
bail commissioner pay issue the bail
commissioner training issue the bail
commissioner ID issue and we're going to
put that in one of the bills that we
have
retained and um I'm going to take a
minute and meet with Linda and figure
that
out
Pur
e
okay we are ready to begin to the
members of the
subcommittee um I after having conferred
with um representative here at gaite
this is what we're going to propose to
the committee for your
consideration we are considering using
House Bill 318 as a vehicle to make the
following
changes RSA 5
972b we are going to increase the fee
for bail Commissioners from $40 to
$50 we are going to mandate that the
court reimburse or pay the bail
Commissioners monthly for any bails done
within the previous
month we are going to authorize the
court to collect that from the
defendants regardless of their indigency
or not the court can make a
determination whether or not they can
pay and over how much time they need for
example if someone's Indigent the court
could say okay you have two years to pay
the
$50 um the court is also free to wave it
if they so choose it's their
budget also HB excuse me um RSA 59718 a
we're going to mandate 16 hours of
initial training for all new bail
Commissioners and eight hours annually
for all bail commissioners to be paid by
the court at $50 per day for each bail
commissioner we will be getting um
there's going to be fi fiscal notes to
these and we will be asking for the
money to cover this until the next
budget the next bium at which point the
court will put it in their
budget and finally
59717 we are going to mandate that the
court either themselves or in an
agreement with the DMV issue a a durable
Commissioners that they will get upon
their
appointment and that's what we're going
to do with regard to the bail
Commissioners and now that's open for
discussion anybody have any questions or
points on the
committee everyone representative Reed
thank you um what about the access to
the computer system will they um
eventually be able to um access
information on the yeah Network we're
going to uh I'm in talking to the
representatives from the court now about
how that would work um I don't know that
we're ready to put it in statute right
now because I don't think that the
infrastructure is quite there yet we are
going to address what we addressed last
year with getting the money for the
police departments to be able to access
it so at the very least they'll be able
to show the bail commissioner the
records there so the the the key part of
that is informing a bail commissioner if
somebody's already out on bail when they
come to bail them so that they can make
an informed decision and we're going to
address that by at least in the in the
short term by ensuring the police have
access to all that information so I'm
still trying to figure that out with the
court but we are going to address it
this um representative rhods then
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman um the one thing that I just
wanted to bring up was you know we heard
so much about training of the bill
Commissioners and and going through my
handy dandy little
notebook um it's interesting because
there actually is I think a three-page
I'm sorry a three paragraph section
where it is already a law that the bill
commissioner is supposed to get paid but
somewhere along the way it appears that
has just been completely disregarded so
the we're not actually changing anything
we're just adding to that about um
minimum hours and and so forth you mean
trained that is exactly what I meant
thank you um so you know if you guys are
looking in there and you see that you
may be as surprised as we were to see
that it already is a law um but we just
you know tweak a little bit of it we
didn't take anything out of that and
also we are going to add um that the uh
the Supreme Court um chief justice or
whoever their designate is reports
annually to the president of the Senate
and the speaker of the house um on the
status of the bill Commissioners with
regard to how many there are their
annual training is um complied with Etc
so that um in the legislature We Have
Eyes on at least what's going on in the
status of all the bail Commissioners in
the state does everyone agree with that
yes we also added Judiciary and criminal
justice committee as well yeah we we
were going to add the um Judiciary
criminal justice committee and the
equivalent in the Senate as well as the
president and the uh the
speaker um and and I think that about
covers it um any further represent
wheeler sorry the only thing I wanted to
uplift Mr chairman is that we heard a
lot from the bail Commissioners that
came to testify that there was a lack of
standardization in the system when it
came to the bail Commissioners and I
think that are adding the eight hours of
annual training for them to be able to
look at the statutes and look through it
will actually really help in
standardizing the system and making it
so that no one's getting out uh based on
a statute that is in the law and should
be keeping them in yeah uh and that's a
good point I think that often when we do
laws we have to um we have to write to
the lowest common denominator and we
know that some courts and some bail
Commissioners um they have excellent
programs the judges have excellent
training um and some from our testimony
we heard it's kind of the Wild West so
we have to write for the wild west and
um so um some bail Commissioners may
feel this isn't necessary but others do
so we we're going to make sure that
everyone gets gets it at least
representative
cther um did you mention that um any Law
changes during the year oh yeah also um
my notes are lacking in that um training
it would say eight hours um annually 16
initial and any changes to the law
occurring during the year that are
driven by a court decision or new action
of the legislature so for example if
they just had their eight hours of
training uh two month later a court
decision comes down from the Supreme
Court addressing bail they would have to
be called back and retrained on that um
but I don't I don't know that we're
going to put in statute that it has to
be inperson physical for an update like
that it could just be that the whoever's
in charge we just have to put in in that
they will be trained on any updates
because I don't want to put that burden
on the court or the um magistrates to
have to go in again just to hear about
one
case but we will mandate that they they
do be trained on
it represent
Muse yeah just a just a couple of things
um one of the things that we've done for
workers and other situations where you
know retention is an issue not not just
attraction um is set things set it up so
that uh uh people can receive retention
bonuses or Rewards or something like
that it would be nice to see something
like that uh included in here um another
another issue is um who actually
oversees this you know and and I think
it's something that we raised uh earlier
uh perhaps creating a part-time position
in I think I have an answer for you
before we get too further um we we are
discussions right now representative
gaite and I with the um with the courts
and we are looking at um potential for
actually bringing in magistrates to um
in I don't want to get too far Mye of
myself because this is a separate
statute we're going to be dealing with
in the next couple days um that would
oversee bail Commissioners within their
region in other words we're not
replacing bail Commissioners we're going
to be adding a position um that's going
to have certain other duties um but they
would be in charge that way you don't
have one person trying to oversee all of
them in the state each geographic region
will know how many bail Commissioners
they have in their region they'll be
responsible for training they'll bear
and Reporting back to the court that
they have complied with the training Etc
so we're going to make sure there's a
chain of answerability as far as that
goes but I I don't want to get too far
ahead of that yet just follow um one of
the bills that we've retained that's in
front of us is HB 318 which would
actually eliminate Bill Commissioners
one of the things we might want to
consider doing is just quickly executing
that um no we're using that as the
vehicle for we're using that yeah yeah
we're GNA we're going to um amend that
and since it's fairly Germaine um we're
going to just go ahead and change it um
representative Stone thank you Mr chair
I'd like to say that uh the bill
commissioner system that we currently
use uh shouldn't never have been thought
of to be abandoned I think these
compromises operationally will put us
back on track where we should be and I
think the bill Commissioners that we
currently have have really endured a lot
over the last uh decade or so of serving
the taxpayers of New Hampshire very
fiscally and I support all these changes
thank you uh represent Stone I I agree
totally I think that the system as it is
um would crumble without the bail
Commissioners um they're intricate um
and necessary part and um as far as as
long as I'm here we won't be considering
uh getting rid of them at all um but we
will we will make sure that they finally
get paid and we will make sure that
there is consistent training across the
board for all of them um did you raise
representative so as you're not going to
shoot down our ideas otherwise you're
going to have to wait so it's you can
nibble go ahead
away time to nibble yes okay thank you
um you asked about uh day-to-day
supervision of bail Commissioners fine
if you want magistrates but the de facto
the way that's done it's the clerk of
the court does that Y and I am routinely
spanked for a form that's not right or I
didn't use it's never really a judgment
call uh it's that's really not it's Mo
mostly a
technical uh
issue um I am
not supporter of increasing the pay what
I am a big fan of is getting the them
paid I don't think the that their
complaint is whether it's 40 or 50 the
complaint is that they're not paid so
that I think we may be overreaching and
I'm that's that's a a nibble another
perhaps nibble that is a more much more
personal one and this this whether I was
on Edna or here I do not like fixed
hours we're going to come eight hours a
year and what are we going to do I'd
like to ask for input from the court
what they think
before we fix before we carve this in
stone is 16 the right number of hours
for the initial I don't really too worry
too much about the
initial I I like the court to to to to
pass on that before we say it I'd like
to see something like a minimum of four
a minimum of four hours and for uh
yearly allow me just to interrupt um
because uh I I it it's my fault for not
saying it first this um structure was
come up came up with in conjunction with
the court speaking with um uh the
Court's representative Aaron um I forgot
her name pardon me um the hours the the
money the training all of it was in
conjunction talking with the courts so
oh all
right uh no vacuums but um uh I agree
though 16 we in discussion um there may
not be 16 well 16 there's certainly
enough uh two days training for a new
bill commissioner the 8 hours and they
can use it to Shadow they can use it
however they want also the the eight
hours annually even if there's only four
hours worth of talking um I think
getting the bill Commissioners together
for a couple hours from the various
regions to talk to each other share best
practices I I don't think anything bad
can come from them actually getting
together and seeing each
other I I just want that to be a serious
thing because you if you have two hours
of talk and four hours to fill now
you're maybe trivializing the thing I
agree and that that that's really what's
at the bottom of my concern I want that
to be meaty time in fact the 16 hours if
that's going to include laboratory time
I know the last the bail commissioner I
trained actually he's probably better
than he's very good one he came with me
and it I'm talking 20 hours I me he was
with me for
many bales that I'm talking about I
couldn't wake him he didn't mind being
wake or he never admitted uh objecting
to be awakened at night one final note I
all right my nibbles aren't you're
you're defanging me and I don't like it
but anyway um I do everything in
anticipation of your bites the um we
just had our bail commissioner's meeting
and I'm a little put out at it we had
two judges one was wanted to be engaged
and involved the
other uh it was his birthday he wanted
to get out of there he was not welcoming
it questions that I had and I said you
might like to hear what's going on with
the criminal justice committee nope if
it's not an RSA I don't want to hear
it what that's that's the at that was
the attitude of a judge I you'd think
that he would want to know what's what's
rustling what's happening
he he I was I I don't want to my
feelings were hurt but they were a
little hurt yeah well certainly
disrespectful I then yeah it it just
wasn't anyway a little glimpse
into my my world of about two weeks ago
anyway thank you for listening and thank
you for sharing um represent wheeler and
then represent
me I mean excuse me wayer represent
Stone thank you Mr I muffins in my mind
yes uh thank you Mr chair the hairs in
regards to the hours I think the hours
are okay being allotted and I certainly
don't want to see anything micromanaged
the Judiciary and that I have a feeling
they can be responsible enough to
dictate the hours of how they want to
break them down within that year for
training yeah and I I think
representative um scitec um suggestion
is actually very um good that we we put
in there uh that at least some of that
should be used to Shadow on on baales
because that uh hearing about it in the
class versus actually getting out there
in the field and seeing it is is totally
different experience so I I think that
is important and we will take that under
enisman as we draft this uh
representative
Muse yeah one one one hopefully minor
issue that I hope we can address is um
allowing the court to collect regardless
of indigency for up to two years kind of
fires our torpedo into the whole concept
of indig indigency it's you know people
basically can't pay um and as a
practical matter when we're talking $40
or $50 chasing people for two years to
pay 40 or $50 doesn't might not be the
most efficient use of the Court system's
time that's why I think that we're going
to leave it up to them to decide if they
want to pursue that but if you start
talking about you know four five 600
defendants with $ in per year it adds up
to significant amount of money that
would be coming out of their budget but
we will leave it up to them to say we
will say if they're Indigent the court
May wave um I mean I I don't want
because someone may be Indigent today
and get a job six months from now and
they could pay that $50 if they are the
stay so that's why I'm leaving it up to
the court and the two years was just the
number I picked that we don't have to
put any time liit they you know I just I
want to leave it with them with the
ability to decide this person can now
pay or they just can't and for us to do
it from here we could be hurting uh
their budget and our budget because
someone could have a job six weeks later
and easily pay the $50 and it was waved
six months ago and now they're off the
hook on it and the taxpayers have to
pick it up so I I feel like if we leave
the court the the room to make the
decision I trust that they'll make the
right decision um as to whether or not
someone's you know you get someone
homeless who who has mental health
issues they're never going to get $50
and I'm hoping the court will be wise
enough to see that and not pursue it um
so if we leave in there the court May
wave um when a defendant is found
Indigent
or pursue it at a later date I mean but
there there's nothing in the changes
that we'd be doing that would actually
um keep an Indigent person who can
afford a baill commissioner um from
actually using a baill commissioner oh
no no no no they no okay no absolutely
not they get the bail commit all that's
taken care of after the F thank you yeah
representative um rhods thank you Mr
chairman okay
so to to representative Muse's question
we do have that written out more
specifically here yeah um better than I
RAM and you know the court is authorized
to make the determination whether or not
they have to pay or not but I think the
thing to keep in mind is you know what
we're saying here is not the entire that
has to be written because there's a lot
of areas where one thing is going to
overwrite another and that's the
attorneys are you going to help us with
that and uh chairman Roy and I met last
week after our house session with the
attorney that's going to that's actually
was assigned to this specifically to
help us and already has a list of all
the the rsas we're looking at because a
lot of them are intertwined and I think
the other thing that I I would like to
stress for everybody to keep in mind is
we heard from a whole whole lot of
people and there there is not one single
thing that every person in this room is
going to love every single part of we
are really trying to go to the entire
state of what is best for every single
person not just the people in this room
or a couple of the people that testified
every single person because all 10
counties are completely different and
need something a little bit different
and remember we have a whole another
body that we have to also get this past
and then a corner office so I think the
thing to keep in mind when we're doing
this is we're not all going to get
everything we want we're not going to
get everything out that we don't want
representative gaite and I back there
had to you know go into our separate
corners for a minute but that's to be
expected but we still came up with
language that we both could agree on
thinking that we all could agree on that
so when we're moving forward I would
just ask everybody to please keep that
in mind it's not about one single person
or one per one County it's about all 10
and the last thing we want is the
taxpayers to have to be paying for
somebody's bail commissioner fees so we
need to make it work for everybody I'm
done with my rant thank you yeah thank
you for that um I I would just say that
I I would like the uh the ability for
the court to get it if they can and if
the you can't get blood from a stone so
I don't want the court going after
someone who who has not the ability to
pay so I think that we just have we I
mean we trust them whether or not to
send someone to jail we should be able
to trust them whether or not to go after
money um from a person who cannot afford
it and I would think that um
they they're they're certainly wise
enough to make that decision um we just
want to leave them latitude um represent
Murray thank you Mr chair do you know if
um right now if someone is unable to pay
that fee like or their release like they
have unpaid fees if they can then be
like arrested again for not paying those
fees I do not believe so representative
scitec do you have any insight into
that I'm I'm not sure I understood the
question question but you are bailed no
matter what yeah but can you be um have
you ever heard of a so when someone's
determined Eng by the court they don't
go after the bail fee later and someone
be arrested for I've never heard of that
yeah nor have I I it's my understanding
that once you detered inent it's just
written off but at the same time the
bill Commissioners aren't get paid so
because that's where they get their
money from now we're putting that onus
on the court to say you're paying the
baill Commissioners and if you decide
the W of the money that's on you that's
your
budget with the allowance that if
someone is Indigent the court can wave
that um representative wheeler well I
just want thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to say it's it's important if
someone's Indigent and that we make sure
that we are being compassionate if
someone doesn't have enough funds but
it's also important that to note bill
Commissioners are doing a incredibly
important service and they're driving
far distances at late hours to be able
to go out and and do what you said this
is a very critical piece to our system
here and they need to be paid um so I
think that's sort of yeah we're going to
try and balance that exctly exactly yeah
agreed um and also just to address what
representative scitech about he wasn't a
big fan of the Rays um we heard a lot
about you know the distances some of
these folks have to drive the price of
gasoline is ridiculous right now rather
than getting into a system where they
were reimburse for mileage you'd have to
hire employees just to track the mileage
it's us to say okay we're going to bump
it to
$50 um it hasn't been raised since
inflation has been spiking um so frankly
I I don't think $10 is that big a deal
and it's in line with what other states
are charging to so further questions
comments okay what I'd like to do now is
hold an informal vote um if everyone's
in favor Mr chairman yes sir ju just a
quick note from the field as somebody
who has bailed Indigent people that's
not a problem I don't mind that at at
all
that's you do that for the team and he's
still Mr Jones as far as I'm concerned
despite many issues I'll tell you what
ra bail Commissioners res I'm not sure
we're going to do anything here but when
you know a defendant knows he cannot be
bailed and he still asks for a bail
commissioner to come in and say that he
doesn't have the money but he just wants
to cycle you that it isn't a good faith
indent it's a guy it doesn't happen
explain how how how he knows he can't be
bailed because there may be a bench
warrant for him yeah and I'm looking at
it and I'm saying based on what the
police have said there are no
circumstances under which I want to let
this person out without has having seen
a judge okay so I want them to ask to
decline a bail commissioner and see a
judge in the morning because I'm not
comfortable letting this person out and
I tell them that you're not allowed to
set a bail by phone but there are some
black and white situations where you
just know I want to see a bail
commissioner I come in I said I've told
you this why are you doing this yeah I
want my bail he had no money by the way
it isn't in that case it's not the money
I'm telling you I don't mind I'm wasting
time now I don't mind a Indigent I I
that's a human being this guy is his
life is lost I'm going to go home to a
warm bed this guy is where is his life
going it's very easy to un not to be
resentful of that it's the people
jerking the system around that are the
anoying thank you yeah thank you
fortunately I I don't I don't know that
there's anything we can do about that
other than try to raise better children
um representative uh Muse yeah one one
last thing um one thing that would be
good to do would be to put something in
here that makes tellah herings more of
an option um those are something that
that's something that we actually
considered as an experiment pre-co when
we had the original Commission on bail
commissioner pay yeah and I think one of
the things that we learned kind of
during the whole Co experience was that
was something that actually works so one
of the things we heard from some of the
uh you know some of the police officers
and some of the county jail Personnel
were just times when bail Commissioners
simply aren't available and as much as
we'd like to try and resolve the
attraction and retention situation there
are going to continue to be issue you
know times when having a bail commission
you know basically not having a bail
commissioner could mean that somebody is
sitting in jail longer than they need to
be sitting in jail so you know one of
the things that you know that that I
would uh that I think maybe we should
consider part of this is is actually
making uh tah hearings uh basically
putting the money equal footing I I'm
I'm correct me if I'm wrong one of the
bail Commissioners that testified she
said that she was still doing um
telephonic bail hearings she did them
during Co and she's still so I I'm not
sure that anywhere in statute it's
prohibited um from conducting a bail
hearing via telephone representative
Stone I would think that this is getting
kind of out of the weeds of what we're
looking at currently and I think at this
point we should focus back on the core
issues operationally if uh the court
seems to in emergency orders situation
where the governor May declare one I
think that should be handled at a
discretionary by the Judiciary and not
by legislative codified no I I just if
uh representative M's point just struck
me that if if it's prohibited I would
not object to saying the court May if it
so chooses conduct or authorize the
conduction due to the shortage in staff
or something like that allow them to do
it but if it's not blocked already it
seems to me they're allowed to do it
that seems like a mo Point yeah um
anything else okay so can I just get by
a show of hands all in favor of us
sending what we just discussed over to
the um over to lb to be drafted so that
we can have an actual real vote on it um
hopefully
tomorrow all in
favor good everyone let the record
reflect everyone let the record reflect
everyone voted yes and we will send this
over to uh legislative services today
and we will vote on it tomorrow to send
to the full
committee and with that we are going to
close for the day tomorrow is going to
be a little more in depth and probably
plan on being here a little bit longer
um we're going to start delving into the
actual issue of reoffending while on
bail tomorrow um that one might not go
as smoothly um but I'm hoping it will
and next week uh we're going to get into
what I discussed with represent Muse a
second ago about um the the management
and supervision and um and the dreaded
13 crimes list from the Senate uh anyone
have anything before we go
representative Murray um just really
quickly for the committee I wanted to
let you know I I um kind of summarized
all of the minutes from the past few
weeks and gave you each a sheet and I
also sent it via email because at the
bottom I hyperlink the minutes to every
hearing so you can see the full minutes
as well and I made a list of everybody
who testified um the only date this
doesn't include is the 20th because I
wasn't present for that and I don't have
the minutes wow thank you representative
Murray you are without a doubt the best
clerk I've even ever heard
ofe and and um I I don't maybe it's not
for me to say but I just want to
congratulate representative Murray on
may you have many years of happiness um
with that we are closed for the day and
I'll see you all tomorrow morning at 10:
thereabouts
that